- Hello. Good afternoon, everybody.
We're so happy to see you here.
I'm just going to say a few
words about the Park lecture.
The Seong-Yawng Park
and Marguerite Clark Park Memorial Lecture
was made possible by a generous
gift from their estate.
The principle objective of this gift is
to foster the study of Korea at Yale
by bringing recognition
of the Korean Peninsula
and its affairs and achievements
both to Yale and to the wider community.
The Parks met at Yale
and were married in 1964.
And in an interview Park gave in 2002,
he said that coming to the United States
and studying at Yale was an experience
that shaped his entire life.
Park earned his PhD at Yale in 1965,
and then taught economics
at the University of California Berkeley.
In 1968, he returned to Seoul
to work as an economic advisor
to the president of Korea,
and he also taught economics
at Sangmyung University.
In 1984, he took over the helm
of Kumho after his father,
who was its founder and
chairman, passed away.
Park continued to build
this transportation,
construction, and electronics company,
establishing Asiana Airlines in 1988,
and thereby forming the Kumho group.
The inaugural Park Memorial
lecture was by Victor Cha,
professor of Government
and International Affairs
at Georgetown University.
Carter Eckhart, Yoon Se Young
Professor of Korean history
at Harvard University, gave
the second Park lecture,
and Jin Y. Park, professor
of philosophy and religion
at American University, gave the third.
And today, it is our great pleasure
to welcome Laurel Kendall,
who is our first anthropologist
to give the Park lecture at Yale.
So, thank you so very much.
- Okay. Thank you so much for coming.
My name is Hwansoo Kim.
I teach Korean religion and culture
in the Department of Religious Studies.
And it's great honor to
introduce our speaker,
Dr. Laurel Kendall.
Dr. Kendall is the curator of
Asian Ethnographic Collections
at the American Museum of Natural History,
and a senior research scholar
at the Weatherhead East Asian Institute
at Columbia University,
and also a former president
of the Association for Asian
Studies in 2016 to 2017.
She earned her BA from UC Berkeley,
as well as her two MA
and a PhD from Columbia.
She is an uncontested,
unparalleled authority
on the subject in Korean shamanism
and her broader research
ranges from shamanism
and gender relations
and religious practice
and material religion in
East and Southeast Asia.
Dr. Kendall began her
passion for Korean studies
when she was working as
a Peace Corps in 1970
when I was born.
That's long time ago.
And she encountered several female shamans
through their ritual performances,
and this encounter led
her to three decades
of anthropological fieldwork,
resulting in three
groundbreaking monographs.
First, "Shamans, Housewives,
and Other Restless Spirits:
Women in Korean Ritual
Life" published in 1985
examines Korean female shamans
with a special focus on gender relations.
Her second book,
"Life and Hard Times of a Korean Shaman,"
published in 1988,
details the life of a Korean
shaman, Yongsu's mother,
who became a close
informant and her friend,
but who passed away
last year unfortunately.
Lastly, "Shamans, Nostalgias, and the IMF:
South Korean Popular Religion in Motion,"
published in 2009, traces the
evolution of Korean shamanism
from being disparaged as
superstition in the 1970s
to be embraced as a religion,
and ultimately being noted
as a fundamental part
of Korean culture in the 1990s.
And actually, I have been using this book
for like 10 years for my class,
religion and culture in Korea.
In addition to her expertise
in Korean shamanism,
Dr. Kendall has also published
a book on gender titled,
"Getting Married in Korea" in 1996.
This book concerned how matches are made,
wedding rights are conducted,
and families finance and carry
out the recorded exchange
of ceremonial goods in South Korea.
The books shed light on
the changing material...
Not material.
Marital roles of Korean women in a society
rapidly transformed in
the late 20th century
by industrial capitalism
and the emergence of a
full-blown consumer culture.
Dr. Kendall's most recent
work concerns the production
and consumption of sacred objects
in contemporary market economies,
and she has conducted extensive
field work in South Korea,
Vietnam, Myanmar, and Bali.
And this research resulted in a book,
"Mediums and Magical Things:
Statues, Paintings, and
Masks in Asian Places."
This book was published
two years ago in 2021.
This book describes how
material images give form
and presence to otherwise
invisible entities,
and how sometimes these
objects are understood
to be enlivened, agentive
on their own terms.
In addition to her five monographs,
Dr. Kendall has also edited
and co-edited six volumes.
It could be more.
And also, at the American
Museum of National History,
she has curated several exhibitions
including "Mythic Creatures:
Dragons, Unicorns, and Mermaids" in 2007,
and "Vietnam: Journeys of
Body, Mind, and Spirit."
And the second exhibition
was a unique collaboration
with the Vietnam Museum of Ethnology
that earned Dr. Kendall a friendship medal
from the Vietnamese government.
And although I have
respect your scholarship
for a long time, this is the first time
I have had the pleasure
of meeting in person.
In fact, in addition to today's talk,
Dr. Kendall has kindly agreed
to give a keynote speech
at the upcoming Ewha and
Yale Conference in Seoul,
scheduled for May 26th.
And after the conference,
all the participant,
including Dr. Kendall and I,
will have a week long trip
in South Korea, field trip,
including places like
Jeju-do, Busan, and Gyeongju.
And my colleagues and I
are very looking forward
to us spending ample time with her.
It's so wonderful to have you here today.
Please join me welcoming
Dr. Laurel Kendall.
- Thank you, Dr. Kim, for
that gracious introduction.
And I consider it a great
honor to be here today
as part of this
distinguished lecture series.
This talk introduces, oops,
sorry, got ahead of myself.
This talk introduces
a comparative project.
I will be looking at Korea.
But not just at Korea.
Vietnam is a part of it,
and there will be a few
words about Myanmar,
and also Bali, Indonesia.
The project resulted in a book
with Burmese nat spirits on the cover.
It addresses a challenge
posited by anthropologist Webb Keane.
He says, "Here is anthropology.
Here, you have an innately
comparative discipline.
It's been comparative from
the moment of its birth,
and yet anthropologists today
are absolutely squeamish
about doing overtly comparative work.
We are embarrassed by the inscriptions
of our Victorian forebearers,
and not happy with the
supposedly controlled comparisons
of mid to late 20th century anthropology.
A bid to be scientific with what we're,
in the end, apples and oranges,
insufficiently contextualized
by their roots and trees."
If I could do anything differently
in the final chapter of my first book,
well, it would probably be to
not write the final chapter,
which is a place where I attempt
to make a gendered comparison
of rituals, gods, ghosts,
purity and pollution in
Korea, China, and Japan
in ways relatively innocent
of historical, geographical,
and class variation within
Korea, China, and Japan.
It was the big statement I needed to,
at the time, to get a publishing contract.
But in retrospect, a mistake.
I will stand by the
rest of the ethnography
between these covers,
but chapter eight is an embarrassment,
an artifact of another time.
I have worked with Korean
shamans since the 1970s,
and I have continued to
write books about them.
The project that I am going to share
with you this evening begins in Korea.
It begins with mansin who are,
I would translate them as shamans.
Not just spirit mediums, but shamans,
master of the spirits.
While a medium could
be considered something
of the spirit's puppet,
possessed, entranced, taken over,
mansin are agentive.
They are expected to, in
the goodwill of the gods,
to pacify ancestors on
behalf of their clients,
to mollify troublesome spirits,
and cast things impure away
from their client's path,
so that is open to
blessing and good fortune.
Their primary work is accomplished
in costumed rituals called kut,
where they are empowered to make the gods
and ancestors a living
and speaking presence.
The gods of the shaman's
pantheon are invisible,
but they become a visible
presence in two ways.
One, they are,
through the mansin's physical
manifestations in kut,
they're mobile, they're vocal,
but this is a temporary presence.
They're more permanently
present in the painted images
that hang above the shaman's altar.
More constant,
but as we shall see,
not completely constant.
The paintings were
backdrop to my early work,
but I did not have
occasion to think very much
about the images that hung
above the mansin's altar
beyond understanding that
these were sacred objects,
that they carried the
identities of the gods
in the shaman's pantheon,
and that they were consequential
for the mansin's work.
I did hear a story about
some paintings of old gods,
hung behind the altar of the mansin
I call Yongsu's mother.
Her sister was also a mansin,
but her sister wanted to give it up
because her sister's
son said, "Live with us,
but you can't be a mansin
if you live with us."
She had dreams. She made prayers.
It seemed like the gods that
she served were quite willing
to go over to Yongsu's mother's shrine
and work with her and her gods.
Now, the shrine was a very narrow space.
And so, Yongsu's mother
took the new paintings
and put them under the old paintings.
This was after they did
all the appropriate ritual.
And the God said, "Yes,
yes, yes, we'll be here.
We'll work with you. We'll help you."
And so, she puts them one under the other.
And then things go south.
She has illnesses. She has
a falling off of business.
Her clients aren't coming
with the usual regularity,
or they're coming for a divination,
then they're going to another mansin
to have them do the more expensive ritual.
And she's having trouble
getting a flow of inspiration
from the gods who are above her altar.
And then she has troubling dreams.
Now, in one dream, some women
come to her for a divination,
three women.
And one of them sits down.
The shaman, she does what a mansin does
when she's about to give an inspiration.
She brings out a tray.
There's rice grains on
it. There are coins.
She's going to throw the rice,
throw the coins through the configuration.
She's going to get some sense
of what's going on with the client.
She'll ask more pointed questions
until she does a full diagnosis.
She's doing this empowered by the theodicy
at the divination tray in the picture,
the Great Spirit grandmother who,
in individual mansin pantheons,
is usually an ancestress
or a teacher shaman,
some shaman in her past who is guiding her
in a lineage type way.
So, the women come in,
and one woman sits at the
other side of the tray,
and the other two, she
says, "Sit down, sit down."
You know, and they say no.
They stand by the door.
And she feels very
uncomfortable in the dream,
you know that these women
are just standing scowling.
And then one of them stalks over,
takes hold of that tray
and upends it on the floor,
and she wakes up and she feels really bad
because this is the rice that belongs
to the Great Spirit grandmother.
And it's like she's been violated.
Her primary deity has been violated.
So, she goes right into her
shrine room, and lo and behold,
the paintings of her own
Great Spirit grandmother
and the painting of her
sister's primary deity,
the jade immortal,
they've stuck together
and fallen to the floor.
And she says, "They'd been fighting."
And I thought, fighting? Who's fighting?
Gods fighting gods.
Paintings fighting paintings.
Gods fighting each other
through the medium of paintings.
And I didn't know what was going on.
And I put the story of the
fallen paintings aside.
It remained like a nagging itch.
I would come back to it,
and I'm going to put it aside
for now and come back to it.
Fast forward and a move
to the north of Vietnam,
early in the new millennium,
where in my work as a curator at AMNH,
I had an opportunity to work
with the Vietnam Museum of Ethnology.
Now, we were doing an exhibit called
"Vietnam: Journeys of
Body, Mind, and Spirit,"
and we had various journeys in it.
And we thought, "Well, let's
include spirit medium journeys,
and we can include the
mother goddess tradition,
which is very rich and colorful."
And Phu Day Temple, the main
seat of mother goddess worship
in the north of Vietnam,
donated to the museum for the exhibit
the three statues that
you see in the back there.
And they saw this as an
attempt to introduce the world
to their religion,
which had been suppressed under
anti-superstition campaigns,
but was back and flourishing
in the new Vietnam.
And then 9/11 happened.
And suddenly, you know,
there was a bit of an economic
crisis in the wake of 9/11.
The American economy had
actually been sliding
a little bit before,
and we were told, "You've gotta
cut your exhibit by a 1/3.
We just don't have the money."
And the statues, which
I hadn't really met yet,
seemed like very good
candidates for cutting,
because they were big, heavy, fragile.
The only way we could safely
get them to New York would be
to buy seats for them on the airplane.
So, the statues were cut.
What do we use in their place?
And we felt we should consult
with spirit mediums at Phu Day Temple.
So, Madam Zwen, the wife
of the shrine keeper,
very formidable spirit
medium in her own right,
was going to come and
talk to us at the museum,
and she was not happy
that we were not going
to use these spectacular statues.
Now, the statues had been kept in storage,
and they'd gotten a little dusty.
So, the conservators,
meaning to do a good thing,
took them outside, put
them on a low platform,
and were dusting them.
And we were standing around saying,
"Geez, they're beautiful.
They're so beautiful."
And Madam Zwen arrives and she walks in,
she sees the conservators
at work, and she says,
"You put them on the floor?
Would you put Ho Chi Minh on the floor?
How can you do that?"
And profuse apologies and sued.
Now, my colleagues were
surprised by her reaction
because they understood,
as I did not understand,
that holy images like these statues,
in a temple setting,
they would be animated
with the spirit essence
of the mother goddesses,
or a Buddha, or whatever,
but that these had not been animated.
That they were, as they
understood it, just statues.
And yet, no, there were
something more than just statues,
and we wanted to find out.
Now, the mother goddess tradition
of Vietnam interested me
as it interests anyone who
knows Korean shaman practice.
Because again, you see
the elaborate costumes,
you see the sequential
appearance of the gods,
you see a mimicking of, you know,
royal dress and hierarchies of gods
that parallel temporal hierarchies
of kings and officials and so on.
So, I really wanted to
learn more about it.
And in 2004, thanks to the
Wenner-Gren Foundation,
my Vietnamese colleagues and I were able
to do a further study.
Vu Thi Thanh Tam and Nguyen Thu Thi Huong
and I went back to Phu Day Temple
and talked to the temple
keeper and talked to,
you know, about, "Tell us,
tell us what these statues meant,
and tell us why it was so
wrong to put them low down
to try to clean them when
our poor conservators
thought they were doing a good work."
And then we went beyond Phu Day.
We talked to other mediums.
We talked to carvers.
We talked to a lacquer maker.
We talked to people who
sold statues in the market.
And at the start of many interviews,
just to explain what we were about,
I told the story of the paintings in Korea
that had fought with each
other and fallen to the floor.
And this was a very good move
because this banished
any perception that me,
as an American, was going to
look down as superstitious,
all this stuff that was going on.
And that I was open to the idea
that images could do things
like fight with each
other and cause bad luck.
And this was the beginning of
my education in magical images
and the start of a comparative project
that would eventually
draw in Myanmar and Bali,
and draw me back to shaman
shrines in South Korea
and the matter of the fallen paintings.
In Vietnam, we were interviewing
carvers, spirit mediums,
ritual masters, et cetera
at a very good moment.
Because under high socialism,
there had been many acts of iconoclasm.
The consequences were very
fresh in people's minds.
You know, they threw
the statues in the pond
and somebody died in a flood.
And this woman who was
telling me this says,
"And I have chronic arthritis, you know,
if only we hadn't done
that to the statues."
Also, the market was back.
Things were looking up,
and there was a felt need to repair,
to restore the fallen statues,
to repair decaying temples.
So, statue carving was very
much on people's minds.
Now, all of my life, all of my adult life,
I have been bowing to
Buddhas showing respect.
I've been guided in my
form by many Korean women.
I never realized that
the Buddha was supposed
to really be there until
I began doing this work.
I was learning what my Vietnamese
colleagues knew very well,
that through ritual acts,
the statues had been made
into social entities.
After being ceremoniously
placed on the altar,
the cavity in the statue
body would be filled
with animating matter,
sometimes regarded as an
approximation of human organs,
amulets, and other things.
And then on a lucky day,
in the dark midnight hour of the rat,
a ritual master or a monk
would bring the statue to life,
awakening its senses, opening its eyes.
Now, we studied the, you know,
what do you do to make the statue alive?
But we also, studied the
protocols for making the statue
what the carvers and the spirit
mediums considered necessary
to make a powerful statue,
and then the statue's subsequent carriers.
When I searched the literature,
studies from India,
from China, from Japan,
I was surprised by how widespread
these ideas seemed to be,
that the images transformed
by ritual action into presence
and that the presence
becomes consequential.
And I was tempted into
further comparative work,
building my own questions
upon an existing scaffold of writing.
In Myanmar, I joined
forces with Erin Hasinoff,
and AMNH research associate
who had been working there
with field assistants Pyi
Pyi Thant and Thei Thein Win,
to interview spirit mediums and carvers.
This was a very, very brief incident,
but it helped to round out the picture.
And then in Bali,
I have had the pleasure of working
with Dr. Ni Wayan Pasek Ariati,
a scholar of religious history,
and a veteran field worker
who will also be participating
in the Ewha-Yale conference
just to bring everything home.
In Korea, I have usually been
a solitary anthropologist,
working sometimes with a field assistant,
but I was learning the
pleasures of teamwork,
especially when different people
have different kinds of expertise.
And when I returned to the
question of the fallen paintings,
I joined forces with Dr.
Jongsung Yang, a folklorist,
and Dr. Yul-soo Yoon, an art historian,
both of whom have had interesting things
to say about shaman paintings.
Both of them now have private museums
with extensive collections and ties in...
You know, they complimented my ties.
All of these collaborations
produced co-authored papers
in English language professional journals,
and a co-authored book
on shaman paintings.
These were cited pieces
in the patchwork quilt
that would become "Mediums
and Magical Things,"
the 2021 book.
And because it had worked
so well for me in Vietnam,
when I met with carvers in Myanmar,
I would use the story of the paintings
that had fought with each
other and fell to the floor
in my conversations there,
and also, with carvers in Bali.
I came to imagine this project
as a wide ranging vicarious dialogue
between conversation
partners in different places
who have never met face to face.
A carver in Vietnam told
me this, I would say.
A mask vendor in Bali told me that.
In a South Korean shaman shrine,
the paintings fought with each
other and fell to the floor.
I approached this work
through three affordances.
Affordances, like, like, you know,
you think of the handle on the coffee cup,
there are all different
kinds of coffee cups,
all different shapes,
but they're, you know, a
simple single operation
that helps bring the cup to one's lips.
And that's how I approached
different ways people had
of talking about how they
make and enliven these images.
Birgit Meyer from the field
of material religious studies
calls for a deeper appreciation
of the process of
fabricating religious things.
And this is my first affordance
of most direct interest for a conversation
about active matter and
its spiritual implications.
And this is an affordance that spans
what we might think of as the
Catholic world originating,
but no longer by any means restricted
to Europe and the East, and you know,
but Europe and the Eastern
Mediterranean originally,
and the Hindu Buddhist world, you know,
way across all of Eurasia, more or less.
Throughout this vast
Eurasian geographic span,
we find places where religious images
have long traditions
of workshop production,
where they have been commissioned
as acts of conspicuous devotion
and produced to a higher level of skill,
where levels of material
consumption enable standards
and hierarchies of value
with respect to materials and craft.
Those who commission install,
and subsequently venerate
sacred images are dependent,
or, well, in the Catholic word,
we don't say venerate the images,
but you know, offer prayers and sincerity
inspired by the statues.
But all right, in both
instances, the Catholic world,
the Hindu Buddhist world,
in the first instance,
these things are being made in workshops.
They're not, you're not fabricating
your individual personal religious object.
And the critical work
then has been entrusted
to other hands.
But, and this is my second affordance,
now we slice that first
affordance in half.
Significant difference
between religious statues
in a Catholic tradition
and religious statues in a
Hindu or a Buddhist tradition,
appreciating that these
are multiple traditions.
Catholic images are
considered sacramentals.
They inspire prayer.
They enable the reception of grace,
but they are not or are
not supposed to be idols.
When they show signs of
life, they're considered,
you know, this is a weird thing.
This is miraculous and or
theologically problematic.
And instances of statues
weeping, flying around,
sweating, inspire very serious
religious investigation.
In the Hindu Buddhist world,
images are made to be
inhabited by gods or Buddhist,
as you saw in the slide of
the Vietnamese carver at work,
and there's a cavity in the back.
Images in the Hindu Buddhist world
are regarded as presences,
consecrated and venerated
through appropriate techniques
and practices, sacred,
powerful, sometimes dangerous,
but also, material objects that
will deteriorate over time.
In these places,
the relative quality of
materials, of craftsmanship,
and some practices we might cautiously,
and heuristically call
magic are consequential
for the image's subsequent career
as an unsouled and agentive thing,
consequential for its
efficacy or absence thereof.
The final affordance in my 4K studies
that fall under the very broad
umbrella of sacred images
in a larger Asian world are
those distinctive traditions
of mediumship and showmanship
that work in conjunction
with the gods or spirits
that possess spirit mediums
and are manifested or are
manifested by shamans.
A doubling of the well-crafted image
and the mobile body as in a Korean kut.
So, three affordances.
There's workshop production
to a high degree of quality.
There's the notion that
the statue contains,
is made to be ensouled,
can be ensouled through ritual practices,
can also be de-ensouled.
And finally, there are specific traditions
where the images work in conjunction
with a shaman or a medium.
We'll say something about how and why.
Okay, this happens in Len Dong in Vietnam.
This happens in Nat Pwe in Myanmar.
And in the Balinese, the temple festivals,
the mask image covers and subsumes
the identity of the medium,
a blending of image and mobile body
when the deity appears
in temple festivals.
My work, I want to emphasize,
thinking of that unfortunate
chapter eight of my first book,
this is not going to be
a controlled comparison.
As will become evident, it
was the unexpected answers
to otherwise legible questions
that made things interesting.
In the carving workshops of
the Red River Delta of Vietnam,
I learned the importance of craft.
Using properly seasoned wood
and working it with a knowing hand,
a knowledge of tradition,
a clear vision in the mind's
eye to make a proper image,
I think thus far, you know,
any sculptor would probably say that,
not just good wood and
excellent skill though,
but in the most traditional workshops,
attentions to things,
we might consider magic.
The wood is cut on an
auspicious day and hours
set by the lunar almanac
after sending out any ghosts
or infelicitous elements
that might have taken up
residents inside the old wood.
And the carver who makes
the cuts is endowed
with a horoscope that sinks properly
with the year, day, month, and hour.
The wood is cut to an auspicious measure
on the scheme attributed to Lu Ban,
the Chinese God of carpentry.
The master carver seeks a
vision of the intended deity
in his own mind's eye
before he begins to carve.
He makes his workers observe
various workshop taboos.
No bare chests. No inauspicious talk.
No laundry hanging over the statue.
No menstruating women touching the statue.
No dog meat consumed.
No garlic or strong smelling herbs
when the final gilding is applied.
Offerings and petitions
punctuate the entire process
from the master carvers offerings
to the goddess before going
to discuss the commission
with a potential patron to
the patron's final inspection
of the finished statue,
and request of the goddess's permission
to bring it to the home temple.
In this process,
it becomes difficult
to parse the difference
between the strictly material practices
and things done for other
reasons, other consequences.
And I want to note when
I speak about magic
in Vietnam or Korea or anywhere,
these places are not
strangers to modern science.
This is something else.
The statues like the communion
host are material things
whose intended work
overflows material logic.
A statue will be less
efficacious, even inauspicious,
where the carver substitutes
cheap branch wood
for more durable core wood,
where improperly seasoned wood rots
or becomes infested with insects,
where the artisan skimps
on the gold lacquer
commissioned by the patron,
or where the product is simply ugly.
If human beings do not punish the carver,
the god's will said one master carver
who considers his own work,
his scrupulous attention
to all these details
as doing the mother goddess's work.
Of course, not all images
are equally efficacious,
nor are they all made with the same care.
A shopkeeper on Hanoi's Hang Quat Street,
hive for these activities,
described a hierarchy of value.
She said the least expensive
and the least efficacious
in her view, statues,
are the ones that are
just sort of chunked out.
You know, so, many types
of the Tenth Prince,
and they're all on the shelf
and you come in and you buy one.
The next are commissioned
through the shopkeeper.
Yeah, I want a Tenth Prince.
And they're made to a...
They're more expensive.
They're made a little better.
They might work a little better, she said.
And then the best are the
statues made by a master carver,
using all of the traditional processes
I've been talking about.
And these of course are the most expensive
and the most efficacious.
Statues, like those that had been gifted
to the Vietnam Museum of Ethnology,
had been made according to
all the procedures for making,
but the process had stopped there.
They then were not ensouled,
but they could have been.
Younger mediums use
less expensive statues.
And they will say, "Oh,
statues are statue.
It's the ritual master
who puts the god inside.
You just need a good ritual master."
But the older mediums associated
with established temples
will say, "Oh, that's naive.
That's even dangerous."
Assuming that badly made
statues are not ling,
do not secure the mother goddess's favor
and will bring inauspicious consequences.
I would find this kind of argument
about what you have to do.
No, you don't have to do
that in other places as well.
And I see this as, this is
kind of a dialogic practice.
It is important to point
out the disagreements
that living people have when
it's a living tradition.
And this is a symptom
of how real it all is.
Where the marketplace offers
a range of market choices,
even for the images of gods.
Now, Myanmar is also
in the Buddhist world.
And albeit Theravada, not Mahayana,
and with a different ritual calendar.
But from what I had read
before going there in 2011,
images are also animated.
Nat spirits are invested with
the nats, butterfly soul,
and live in close association
with spirit mediums
who carefully tend them,
bathe them, dress them.
Note the arrangement in the basket.
They've arrived at the festival,
and now the statues have not
been piled inside the basket,
which would be more protective,
would also be an economy of space.
No, the nats should see where we're going.
So, they're out, you know.
I had been curious about
the Burmese nat play
for a very long time.
Again, this is another
kind of ritual where,
like the Korean shaman's
kut, like the Len Dong,
it's richly costumed,
the gods appearing in this
sequence of incarnation
that accompanies costuming
and departure decostuming,
and on through a sequence.
I wanted to see, in terms of this project,
if the workshops that carved the medium
small wooden images, were
attentive to both magic and craft
as their counterparts in Vietnam might be.
I learned that, in Myanmar,
mediums carry their own images
with them to rituals as
their co-present enablers
and to festivals in
the nat's home temples,
where the little images
are periodically irradiated
by their presence to the source statues,
the original seats of the nat.
This is a more portable
practice than the immobile stat.
In Vietnam, the ritual
master sets it on the altar.
And if, you know, one medium
told me she was dusting
and she knocked it a little askew,
and she had pain in her
arms and so on and so forth
until she got a ritual master
and just set it right again.
But no, these are quite mobile.
They go with the, nat draw the mediums,
and they get a bit banged up.
Ethnographies of Myanmar described
their battered condition.
I didn't see batter. I saw, as in Vietnam,
a moment where people could
afford to regild their images
and things were looking pretty good.
When we spoke to the carvers
near the Mahamuni Pagoda in Mandalay
and the Shwedagon Pagoda in Yangon,
carvers were familiar with our questions.
Yes, the carver should
abstain from alcohol
and work with a clean body
and a respectful attitude,
shoes removed as in a
pagoda or a monastery.
And yes, the statues must
be beautifully carved
according to a proper prototype.
A ritual offering might
mark the start of a large
and important commission.
And depending on the
client's willingness to pay,
a carver would observe different
levels of Buddhist precept.
But we soon realized that our interest
in nat images was
confusing to the carvers,
the carvers we were talking to
who considered the nat a sideline.
The Buddha images were where
it was really happening.
And when they described
prohibitions and purifications,
they were largely
referencing carving a Buddha
for a major temple commission.
In addition,
the form of a Buddha image
demands strict adherence
to precise protocols set down in texts.
While not images, need only
approximate the gestures
and costumes deployed by mediums.
And sometimes, a medium will see the nat
in a particular gesture in a dream,
and that becomes the gesture of the image.
And one carver said he felt
happier when carving the Buddha
because he could focus
his whole mind on it.
The nats, he said, could
be rougher and cruder
than a well-finished Buddha image.
I have since heard that
there is a special fraternity
of nat carvers who do take
the carving very seriously,
but they're a small, small
corner on the supply.
It's like in Vietnam,
are you going to buy
a very elegant statue?
Are you going to buy a lesser?
But there seemed also to
be a bit of a difference
between mother goddess figures in Vietnam
and nat figures in Myanmar.
There's such a very clear hierarchization.
The Buddha is absolutely central,
and the nats are something else again.
Nats are relative to the
Buddha, that they died,
most of them died violently.
They died through treachery
or otherwise badly.
These are not spiritual
people or spiritual entities.
In dying, they were unable to
assume a prayerful orientation
toward the next life.
They were denied reincarnation.
As Burma scholars described them,
nats remain trapped in the emotions
and appetites they bore while alive.
While where good Buddhists
work towards salvation
by periodically following precepts,
enjoining moral behavior,
fasting, temperance, and other austerity,
the nats exemplify the appetites
and failings of the flesh
in the stories told about them,
the corporeal activities
they enact via their mediums,
and the rowdy and transgressive behaviors
of oystering devotees on the
periphery of nat festivals.
But unlike the transcendent Buddha,
nats are the guys to whom you
bring your mundane concerns,
your love affairs, your business,
your gambling aspirations.
You don't, you just don't
bother the Buddha with that.
It's totally improper, but
the nats are there for you.
So, they get taken care of.
Nat images are, of course, cheaper.
The wood is of less quality.
They can even be made out of plastic.
Although when I was in Myanmar,
it would be virtually impossible
to find a Buddha image
made out of plastic.
This is not an argument
that the images are necessarily shabby.
They're as nice as the medium can afford.
And it's not an argument
that like some traditions,
they're intended to decay.
No, they're supposed to last
as long as they possibly can.
Rather, the accessibility and
portability of these images
is a reflection on the accessibility
of the nats themselves.
Acquisition is a personal
rather than a community project
the way commissioning a
Buddha image would be,
and these small and relatively
inexpensive images circulate freely.
Little nat are carefully
tended by their medium
and coiffed in at least some cases
with the medium's own hair.
Now, I was ready to go back to Korea
and learn more about the images of gods
that had been fighting
and fell to the floor.
Of course, once we turn
to the mansin shrine,
we're talking not about statue bodies,
but about two-dimensional
paintings on laminated paper,
and sometimes even cheap, garish,
mechanically reproduced prints.
Now, I knew that when
mansin install Buddha images
on their altars, this is a
relatively recent practice,
they mimic Buddhist eye-opening rituals
or higher monks to do this for them.
And in the Buddhist world of animation,
the container of a statue body
has a liturgical certainty.
You do the ritual properly
and it should happen.
It should be enliven
so long as the procedures
are carried out correctly.
But when I asked how the
gods enter the paintings,
I encountered a certain vagueness.
"We caused the gods to be
there," one mansin said.
And no, there's no
special ritual for this.
The gods go into the paintings.
The mansin needs them to be there
in order to receive inspiration
in the form of bright energy,
what they call 'myonggi.'
And this is supposed to happen
when the mansin sees them
in front of her eyes as part
of the initiation ritual.
I realized that, back in 1989,
Diana Lee and I had actually captured
such a moment in our film, and
I will share this with you.
(speaking in a foreign language)
(drumming)
- [Dr. Kendall] Okay, she says,
"You know, if you'd gone up
there and nothing had happened,
that really would've been a disaster."
And so, what's happened here?
She has told her, "You
have to act like a god
to feel the inspiration to be the god."
And then it comes through and she's told,
"Go in, go into your shrine."
And you know, now, you know, bow,
and that connection is established.
The gods have taken their
seats in the paintings.
Oops. Like much in shaman practice though,
it is all a bit ambiguous.
It's not like you do the
ritual, the god's there.
The statue enclose it.
In fact,
the painting is conceptualized
something like a seat,
and a god can get up from that seat.
The gods might not arrive at all,
and the initiation might fail
and the paintings go back to the shop.
Or a charlatan mansin performs
as though the gods were
present in the paintings,
but the paintings are empty
and only the other mansin know this.
Or the gods might arrive,
but they don't have the force
to really make the shaman
an effective shaman.
As alas, that was the case
in the segment you just saw,
that poor young woman,
she just didn't have enough inspiration
to get up the next day
and be a shaman speaking
on behalf of clients,
and she had to work at it further.
This is an ongoing relationship too.
The gods are in the
paintings, but it's ongoing.
It's like a marriage. You know?
They might have a falling out.
The transmission of inspiration
through the paintings might turn staticky
because the shaman has done something
that displeases the gods
as when Yongsu's mother
offended her own gods
by bringing in her sister's gods.
And she said, "And I pray to them
and I used to get this
clear flow of inspiration,
but when that was going
on, it was just static."
Or once present gods might
depart in a fit of peak,
just leave utterly, leaving
the mansin to silence.
No voice, no dreams, no visions,
no body cues, or other intuition.
Sometimes, the mansin
can make it right again
as Yongsu's mother did, and sometimes not.
Some mansin and the very
few traditionalist painters
who remain in South Korea
consider the careful production
of a painting.
The painter engaging
with the shaman's vision
and observing workshop
protocols that would be legible
in the carving workshops
in Vietnam and Myanmar
and Bali as essential to
the flow of inspiration
through the painting.
It is said that the paintings by Mr. An,
whom you see in this picture,
have a very high success rate
when they are used in initiation rituals.
And this man has more
work than he can handle.
I interviewed Mr. An and
another traditionalist painter,
both of whom claimed that
they sat with a mansin
until they could share her vision.
You know, what did you see?
What color was the robe?
What gesture was the hand?
And when they both feel confident
that the painter can reproduce it,
and then they bathe, they
report to the gods and Buddhas
before beginning their work.
They live like monks for the
duration of the commission
in isolation and austerity.
Mr. An said, "I just don't go outside.
I might see an accident.
I might see a quarrel.
And that would affect the painting,
the whole spiritual
connection to the project."
And both painters related wondrous tales
of their engagements
with gods and paintings.
Mansins who could afford their work,
considered these paintings
a mark of distinction
and good practice.
But in truth, in South Korea,
most mansin used paintings
that are either produced
in commercial workshops
or the commercial prints.
When pressed on this point,
even mansin who are proud of their own
traditionally produced,
very expensive paintings,
will give primacy to the
mansin's connections to the gods.
A mansin with strong hobby,
strong compatibility with the gods,
draws them to the paintings
and makes them want to stay there.
And even, some mansin, she said,
could work even with a photograph.
The shaman fosters a good
relationship with her gods
through her own daily devotions.
This is her responsibility,
and she makes pilgrimages
to sacred mountains
to recharge her spiritual batteries.
This is an analogy that
they use themselves.
There was a lot of electricity
talk in these interviews.
I came to see the mansin's body,
the shrine, and the mountain,
as something like electrical circuitry.
The mansin transmitting
back from the mountain
to the shrine to the
gods seated in the images
who provide a steady flow of inspiration
in the form of words, bodily
sensations, dreams, visions,
or probably most often,
just very sharp intuition.
Not a fixed container like the statue,
the painted image is also
more fragile, mutable.
They become soiled with
incense and candle smoke
and are sometimes gwaned
on by bugs or rats.
Gods in the mansin world
prefer pure, clean things.
When the shaman can
afford to replace them,
the gods are politely told,
"Can you abandon your seat for a minute?"
And they take the painting down, burn it,
and replace it with a nice clean one,
and invite the gods back.
While statues are tenderly repaired,
the painting is in effect
treated like an old skin.
Paintings from the shrine
of a retiring shaman,
if not passed to a successor,
would be buried with the
rest of her paraphernalia
in a mountain grave.
We do this for people and
we do this for them too.
She meant the gods.
A mansin explained that
the proper disposition
of departed gods enacted
through the medium
of paintings rotting,
corpse-like, in the ground,
although of course the paintings had,
the gods had been asked
to leave the paintings
before they were buried.
This lack of fixity, this
absence of liturgical certainty,
this ultimate reliance
on the variable powers
of the mansin to draw
the god's inspiration
through the painting
suggests to me a distinction
between the Korean mansion as a shaman,
herself, a master of the
spirits fully agentive,
in contrast with the (speaking
in a foreign language)
In Vietnam.
(speaking in a foreign language)
Myanmar.
Also, who, for the most part,
experienced trance as more
passive vehicles of the divine,
the equivalent of the statue container.
In other words, by
looking outside of Korea,
and then coming back to Korea again,
I saw a productive contrast
that affirmed my sense
of what Korean shamans are.
The success of kutt is very
much a matter of the connection
between the mansin and her gods.
If she enjoys her favor
and if her gods themselves are powerful,
then they send her good inspiration.
Her manifestations are compelling.
Clients laugh and weep in the
presence of gods and ancestors
and receive uncannily accurate
or at least experientially
resonant divinations.
The favor that the mansin
receives is transmitted
to the favor that the client receives,
and the kut is a success.
The shaman's own identity and reputation
are closely identified
with a success or failure
of the kut she performs.
Now, as an elaboration of this point,
here is a brief contrast
with the expectations
of a divine manifestation
by mansin in a Korean kut,
and the spirit entities
who inhabit masks worn
by spirit mediums in
temple festivals in Bali.
In Bali, local tutelary
gods, the sesuhunan,
go to ground in temple masks
that have been carefully carved
and ritually animated according
to exacting protocols.
Very similar to what
I've been talking about.
The masks of particular
temples gain renowned
as particularly powerful sesuhunan.
This is Jero Amerika who
resides in the private temple
of the former rulers of Ubud.
The mask is famous for propelling
Jero Amerika, a medium,
well, through the medium,
the mask on the medium,
on long itinerating journeys around
and beyond the town of Ubud
to neutralize practitioners of black magic
to protect the town.
I saw Jero Amerika in action once
and heard many accounts
of other occasions.
The medium was in the innermost courtyard
on that one occasion when I was present.
The medium was meditating,
and it was told to me by
people who was there that,
ahead of schedule, the medium
is inspired, puts on the mask,
comes down to the temple,
courtyard, does a few turns,
and then runs out of the temple,
followed by all these guys
who've been waiting for this moment.
And they go for the next several hours,
all through the streets of Ubud,
and it all get, and people
fall into very violent trance.
It all gets posted on social media.
And you know, as was related
to me by the people in my hotel
who knew where I had
been the night before.
So, I wanted to, of course, I
wanted to interview the medium
and using a field assistance connections
with the interior of the Palace of Ubud,
we were given a name of the spirit medium
who we were told had done the ritual,
and we spent the better part
of a day tracking him down.
We chased and chased. He
was here. No, he was there.
And then finally, we got a hold of him,
and he said, "No, that wasn't me.
They thought it was me
'cause I'm a famous guy,
but that wasn't me.
That was somebody else."
Now, that would never happen
with a mansin and a kut.
It's her could and the
gods working through her.
In Bali, it's the sesuhunan
who've gone to ground in the mask,
and it's the mask much
more than the medium.
Albeit the medium is not inconsequential,
but that really makes it happen.
Okay, so in conclusion,
the aim of this journey has
not been to make a typology,
or god forbid, a particularly
Asian interpretation.
Rather, it is to present a
wide ranging conversation
enabled by some broad general principles
about materiality and magic
among mediums and shamans,
carvers and painters in my four examples.
As I moved through them,
things learned in one place
could be productively upended
in another domain of
popular religious practice.
Statue workshops in
Vietnam introduced the idea
of statue making as an unfolding
of craftsmanship, protocol,
and magic to produce an
efficacious agentive object.
The Myanmar example offered
a variation on the theme.
Nat images are made more casually
and at less cost.
Material conditions that
reflect the nats' subordination
to the Buddha
and the general accessibility
and portability of nat.
Balinese carvers would see
something of themselves
in the Burmese and
Vietnamese counterparts.
Paper images in Korean shaman shrines
counter the gravitas
of the statue container
with a more ambiguous spirit presence
that witnesses the god's more fluid
and dynamic relationship with the mansin.
The importance of the mansin's agency
in sustaining the flow of inspiration.
Something I would not have
appreciated to the same degree
had I not used what I had learned in Korea
to make questions posed in other places
that generated questions
and some surprising answers back in Korea.
Less a comparison than a dialogue.
And speaking of dialogue, I
want to end this presentation
with an expression of gratitude
to my research partners
and to all of you for staying with me
through this rather long presentation.
Thank you.
- [Audience Member] Thank you so much.
This was fascinating, to say the least.
Please excuse my ignorance
in advance, but...
Once a statue is unsouled,
does the spirit stay
in it or does it leave?
And then there's a need for
another ritual to call it back?
And does it depend on where the statue is?
Let's say, it's in the temple,
therefore the spirit stays.
Could you enlighten us on this?
- Okay. As I understand
it, all the activity
around the statue, around
the mask, around the,
well, in the three places
that use carved wooden objects
is on the assumption that
the deity should stay.
Now, there are occasions where, again,
the deity sent away.
You need to repair your statue.
And there's special protocols for that.
There's also, some disagreement, you know.
Do you have to do a full desacralization
if you are just going to
repair it inside the temple
versus taking it to the carver's workshop?
You know, these little nitty gritty things
that people do argue about.
I heard stories in particular,
one of the encounters that got
me interested in all of this.
A village where during an
anti-superstition campaign,
they were ordered to take the statues down
and throw them in the village pond.
And women describe praying, you know,
"Please leave and please forgive us.
It's the government that's
doing this. It's not us.
It's their fault."
And you know, to enable
the gods to depart.
There are stories throughout
the Hindu Buddhist world,
there's some understanding
that, as in the Catholic,
a Catholic statue loses its
blessing if it's banged up.
And that's, you know,
that's not an incarnation,
that's just a, you know,
a special grace state
in this world where the gods are there.
There is also some sense that,
if it's banged up and
disrespected, the gods leave.
But that's, you know, that deals,
that has to do with the inadequacy
of the material container,
or I guess, you know,
true acts of desecration,
like iconoclastic moments.
So, that's an interesting comment.
Whereas in Korea, you know,
they go up, they go down,
it's a much less permanent thing.
Because it's a relationship
that has to constantly be reaffirmed.
- [Audience Member] Hi,
thank you so much for coming.
This is so interesting.
I was wondering if you had like,
maybe like a personal experience
with Korean shamanism,
because I'm assuming you were
in a close proximity to it.
And I wonder if you had the opportunity
to experience maybe
contacting your own ancestors.
Just outta curiosity.
- Contacting your own ancestors?
Well, through the shamans, yes.
I have sponsored quote for the
dead on behalf of my parents,
and I've been addressed by my dead parents
who speak much better Korean than I do.
And, but you know, with some americanisms
like "Okay" thrown in.
I had one of those twilight
experiences where...
When my father was ill with cancer,
I remember him touching
my back and saying,
"Oh, I can feel your ribs,"
and me thinking you shouldn't
be worried about my weight.
We're all worried about your weight.
And then when we were doing our,
I sponsored a ritual after his death
and the shaman comes up, incarnating,
manifesting my father and
feels my back and says,
(speaking in a foreign language)
You know, I can feel your bones.
I can feel your ribs.
And I thought, "Whoo, this is weird."
You know, how did she,
you know, this is...
And I thought it's all in my head.
I imagined it, but no,
Diana Lee got it on film.
I can't say all of my
encounters are that vivid,
but that one, that one stands out for me.
- [Audience Member] Thank
you for the fascinating talk.
I found myself having
lots of different thoughts
about different things
I've seen over the years
that I've realize now I
probably didn't understand,
and my question may well reveal
just how little I understand.
But I was thinking about stupas
and relics and the way...
Even, so, in the Beinecke library here,
we have the Hyakumanto Darani.
And my understanding of the
efficaciousness of the darani
was that there were
supposed to be the words
spoken by the Buddha.
And so, I was thinking
about how all of that works
and whether there are connections there.
And then it also led me to thinking
about the question of mummies.
So, instead of what we would consider
an inanimate object being animated,
you have the kind of opposite where...
what we would've once considered
to be an animate object
seems no longer to be,
and yet continues to be
revered as if still alive.
Sorry, I'm revealing
my own prejudices here
with the way I'm saying
that, but you know.
And I'm just wondering if
you see connections there,
generally across north and
southeast Asia as well.
- Okay. Mummies, I will say
I know pretty much zero.
Are you talking about those
traditions where like a Daoist
is supposed to eat a certain kind of wood,
and then their body is preserved
from putrefaction or...
- I was thinking mainly of Koya-San
and (indistinct) who's
supposedly still alive.
And everyday, the monks bring him his food
and he's supposedly
sitting there meditating
hundreds of years later.
So, sorry, I'm not very coherent.
This is not really a
question, but I kind of-
- No, it's interesting.
I mean, these are all topics for you
or your students to take on.
These are, you know...
This is all under the
banner of material religion.
There, you know, as, you
may know, some people know,
my students get very upset
when people use the word object
because they've all taken
a course on thing theory.
And if it's not an artifact,
you call it a thing
because it's so much more than
just the material limitations
of what it is.
And there are so many things
that could be studied to,
you know, how do people think about 'em?
How do people argue about
what they're supposed
to think about them?
What's the proper care and
feeding of such an object?
And, you know, it's, there
are infinite examples.
There's all kinds of interesting
work that can be done.
With respect to the mummy,
I guess the thing most resonant to me is,
what is it about the human form?
These are all, you know,
in one instance, the mask,
it's just the head with the medium body,
but the others are all...
What does it mean to
replicate a human form?
Does it conjure a presence?
Museum mannequins,
people have all these Night at
the Museum responses to them
because they're human
forms in human sizes,
not like big statues on pedestals.
It's just a big sea that, you know,
to jump in and swim in and get more from.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
I know nothing about the spiritual world,
So, it was really eyeopening
for me to see that world
through things as you did.
I had this preconceived
concept that the spirit mediums
had this special connection
to the spiritual world
and that object as
supplements to the world.
But the way you paint
it is how that no one,
including the mediums, can
reach the spiritual world along,
and actually they need the objects
or paintings to get inspired.
Therefore, it's the carvers
or painters are critical part
of the efforts and how incredibly
communal that effort is,
and how it is not an
individual relationship
to the spirituality.
And I imagine that that
communality or how that belief,
the spiritual relationship
is only possible
through the communal collective
efforts is heightened
and highlighted through rituals.
But I was wondering, in a
mundane, everyday settings,
how the kind of collective relationality
to spirituality manifests
perhaps differently,
or how that, no...
Just the practiced or felt in that moment
when that's not in a no
spiritual performative moment.
- Okay, that's a very good question.
Thank you. I mean...
These different representations inhabit
different sociality social worlds.
In the case of the Korean
shamans, every day, they...
In the morning, they burn
candles. They offer water.
This is so, and they
address their deities.
And then there is this
kind of playful, ongoing,
the shaman receives a gift,
it goes first onto the altar,
and it's essence gets
consumed by the deities,
and then she takes it back.
Sometimes, there'll be a dream.
One of the deities,
and the mansin I worked with most closely,
one of the deities was...
The person appointed to be that deity
was her dead husband who
had been an alcoholic.
And every now, she described one incident
where she gets this wild
craving for Korean soju
and has to run to the store
and put all the bottles
under the painting.
And so, no, it is ongoing. It is daily.
But it's in the more intimate
sphere of one practitioner
and her deities.
Or in Myanmar, the daily
tending of these little images,
it's almost like doll-like devotion.
But I didn't want to talk about dolls
because it's so freighted
with psychological stuff
that I didn't want to impose
on the Burmese spirit mediums.
But no.
No, it is a sense of continuous presence.
It's just that in the ritual moment,
then the deity becomes manifest
in the medium or the shaman,
and that's it.
But the communities are
different when you make, say,
a Buddhist image in a
community in Myanmar,
it's the whole community
working on it when you...
Well, you know, feeding the carvers,
and maybe doing some Buddhist precepts
to help everything along.
When you carve a mask
in a Balinese community,
the community is feeding the carver,
and there are members of the community
who are in the temple meditating
before the carving starts,
and there's this great sense
of collective enterprise.
The shaman work,
and I would say the nat work
is much more individualistic-oriented
in terms of the
relationship on the one hand
and the ministry of the clients
who are bringing their
own special problems in.
- [Audience Member] Thank you so much
for such a fascinating talk.
I guess my question is sort of remaining
in the mundane world a little bit.
And just thinking about what
happens in a couple of cases
when these objects are
removed from the communities.
And so, you described, you
know, there is a market
in some sense or another
for these objects.
And you know, the more you
pay, the better the efficacy.
What happens, I mean,
I feel like these days you can go
to any kind of garden center or whatever
and pick up a statue of a Buddha.
And I wondered how your interlocutors feel
about this use of these kinds of statues.
And then on a more serious note,
what are the implications?
And I'd just love to hear
you talk a little bit
about what happens when these objects
become curated in museums,
and how do you negotiate
those kinds of moves.
- To the last part of your question,
I could do a whole hour on that, but...
And there's a range of stuff.
There are, most of what ends,
well, no, I can't generalize.
Museums are getting more
savvy and sensitive now.
There's writing, for example,
on if it's a consecrated
Tibetan image, you can image it,
do an x-ray and see if it has
consecration material in it?
If it has the consecration material in it,
is it still carrying the charge or not?
Do you call in a Tibetan
monk to maybe revivify it,
or remove it, or deal
appropriately with it?
It's, at least, as varied as this stuff,
I was talking about in
answer to the last question.
Museums are doing different
things in different ways.
But over the last 30 years,
we have seen a huge uptick
in the sensitivity of museums
to the prior lives and meanings
of the material in our care.
In the American Museum of Natural History,
we have, deep in our storage,
something we call the smudge room.
And it's a room, where among other things,
Native Americans can come in,
take sweet grass and purify objects,
and it won't set off the smoke detector.
The fire service will
only respond to heat.
And it's also been used by Tibetans.
It's been used by visiting Siberians.
It's a special sacred space set apart.
The museum made that commitment
to recognizing these needs.
So, oh, no, there are lots
and lots and lots of stories
that can be told about museum responses
to the sacredness of objects,
and I would say it's a
growing consciousness.
When we did our new Northwest Coast Hall,
you would walk down the
anthropology corridor,
you know, the non-public space,
and on the door of one of
the conservator's areas,
if this room contains shamanic objects,
they may be dangerous to certain persons.
Please be aware.
And then the empowered things were covered
when they weren't being worked on,
and it became a kind of laboratory culture
that developed in
consultation with the people
who were the descendant community.
And we all love it.
I mean, this is anthropology
comes home, full circle.
And then, what was the first question?
- [Audience Member] It was just,
I just wonder how your
interlocutors felt about the,
I guess, non-religious use-
- Oh, non-religious use.
Yeah.
I think, again, you
would find a huge range
from the people who say,
"Well, it wasn't made to
be sacred, so who cares?"
to the people who are saying,
"That's disrespectful,
and that's disturbing,
and that's only gonna bring bad luck."
I mean, just, you know,
just a range of stuff.
They, what I've looked at,
and I do mention a bit in the book,
is things that fall into the art market,
and when, where, and how that happens.
And you know, the stories
that might arise around that.
And some shamans who say,
"Well, they know. The
gods know that, you know,
the shop isn't for them,
the museum isn't for them.
They take off."
And with the statue, some
general assumption again
that they have been deactivated.
And some dealers who will
treat things with respect,
"I'd never put it on the
floor. It goes on a shelf."
- [Audience Member] Can
I ask you a little more
about the materials going in the niches
in the back of a statutory?
I know a lot of work's being
done in Chinese Buddhism
for what's in,
can you say a little bit
about the relationship
in different countries
or different figures
between what goes in and
the type of ensoulment-
- Oh, okay.
- [Audience Member] Or
anything on that line.
- Okay. They will say, I mean,
what I've heard is that
even within Vietnam,
it's highly variable.
I haven't heard in Vietnam,
for example, of putting,
but you know, and then you
compare and it's variable.
But in general, it's five
precious metals or substances.
It's sometimes five colored strings.
You know, the colors of the cosmos.
And some people say that's the intestines,
a lot of amuletic
material, sometimes metal.
I have seen the interiors,
the stuff come out of Tibetan statues
that includes even things
like watch bearings
because they were
probably the right metal,
but I don't know for sure.
I have heard in,
well, there's been a lot of work done
on this cache of statues in China
that contain various material medica
related to the work the statue's
supposed to do in Taiwan.
Sometimes poisonous bugs and insects.
And then some people say, "But
that's never for a Buddha,
that's for the ones that are supposed
to help you in business."
Now, that's aggressive.
So, no, highly variable but
recognizable where people say,
"Oh, yeah, unlike me.
You know, what? You
put stuff in the statue
and bring it to life, and
I'd never heard of it?"
This is a very, you know,
comfortable acknowledgement
across the span
that I've been talking about.
- [Audience Member] So, I'm
interested in the combination
of statues in this picture,
I'm wondering, are they
just a random bundle?
Or like, are they combined together
to add up to the efficacy?
- Are they combined to,
they are the nat who have been identified
as working with a particular
medium on the basis of dreams,
on the basis of the nat goes to a festival
and the music for a
particular nats played,
and he or she dances wildly and they say,
"Oh, you've gotta observe them."
And then they get an image at some point.
And the quest for the perfect image
can be quite interesting too.
There are different stories
about finding the right statue.
- [Audience Member] Okay.
Why don't I just ask the last question?
A more broader question about shamanism,
and then we can close the event.
So, do you think shamanism
is on the rise now?
'Cause I think-
- Think it's on the rise.
Oh, gosh, it's so hard to quantify.
If you had asked the reverse question,
do I think it's dying
out now, it's irrelevant.
I'd say absolutely not.
- [Audience Member] Absolutely not, okay.
- Yeah, it seems to be flourishing.
But, you know, you have
to weigh that against,
you know, to the degree to
which it had to be underground
at certain periods.
So, is it more now or is it
just more out in the open?
I don't know.
There are organizations in South Korea
that claim they have
statistics on shamans.
I don't believe it.
They have statistics on people who admit,
people who've paid admission
to a particular shaman organization.
There are many, many more
I'm sure than the statistics.
But people also fall out of the practice
even though they're not supposed to.
So, I would just say, yes, there are,
it's emphatically not on decline.
- [Audience Member] Mm-hm. Mm-hm.
Yeah, because I'm teaching Korean religion
and culture course, often,
students say that their parents,
although they're Catholic or Christians,
they often consult with
fortune tellers and shamans.
So, apparently, although they
had not reveal their practice,
but definitely a lot of people
are practicing shamanism.
And then-
- No, and there is also,
here's something that might account
for what seems like more.
There are people who,
you know, 40 years ago,
they would just call themselves
a fortune teller, a diviner,
and not a really initiated shaman.
Nowadays, I think the
impulse is to cast yourself
as a shaman to even wear robes and all,
even though whether or not, you know,
these old ladies that I worked
with would recognize them
as shamans because
there's more cache to it.
- Then thank you so much
for your illuminating talk
and thank you so much for just coming.